Let's talk about convolutional networks,
or convnets.
Convnets are neural networks that
share their parameters across space.
Imagine you have an image.
It can be represented as a flat pancake.
It has a width and a height.
And because you typically have red,
green, and
blue channels, it also has a depth.
In this instance, depth is 3,
that's your input.
Now imagine taking a small
patch of this image and
running a tiny neural network on it,
with say, K outputs.
Let's represent those outputs
vertically, in a tiny column like this.
Now let's slide that little
neural network across the image
without changing the weights.
Just slide across and vertically
like we're painting it with a brush.
On the output,
we've drawn another image.
It's got a different width,
a different height, and
more importantly,
it's got a different depth.
Instead of just R, G and
B, now you have an output that's
got many color channels, K of them.
This operation is called a convolution.
If your patch size were
the size of the whole image,
it would be no different than
a regular layer of a neural network.
But because we have this small patch
instead, we have many fewer weights and
they are shared across space.
A convnet is going to basically be
a deep network where instead of having
stacks of matrix multiply layers, we're
going to have stacks of convolutions.
The general idea is that
they will form a pyramid.
At the bottom you have this big image
but very shallow, just R, G, and B.
You're going to apply convolutions that
are going to progressively squeeze
the spatial dimensions while
increasing the depth, which corresponds
roughly to the semantic complexity
of your representation.
At the top you can put your classifier.
You have a representation where all the
spatial information has been squeezed
out and only parameters that map
to contents of the image remain.
So that's the general idea.
If you're going to implement this,
there are lots of little details to get
right and
a fair bit of lingo to get used to.
You've met the concept of patch and
depth.
Patches are sometimes called kernels.
Each pancake in your stack
is called a feature map.
Here, you're mapping three
feature maps to K feature maps.
Another term that you
need to know is stride.
It's the number of pixels that you're
shifting each time you move your filter.
A stride of 1 makes the output
roughly the same size as the input.
A stride of 2 means it's
about half the size.
I say roughly,
because it depends a bit about what
you do at the edge of your image.
Either, you don't go past the edge,
and it's often called valid
padding as a shortcut.
Or you go off the edge and pad with
zeros in such a way that the output
map size is exactly the same
size as the input map.
That is often called same
padding as a shortcut.